visit expressvpn.com yang and get three
extra months of expressvpn for free
[Music]
[Applause]
if infrastructure is all that enables
commerce
and prosperity and our economy to
function
what could be more fundamental than
caregiving
child access to child care access to
elder care support for people with
disabilities
that is essential infrastructure that
we've never
ever invested in which is why we have
all these black and brown women who are
working in jobs where they can't survive
trying to live off of seventeen thousand
dollars a year
without health care the people who are
currently doing it are
exploited they're predominantly women of
color uh
turnover sky high in this industry
because it's so brutally difficult
so what is the plan to transition from
the current economy to the caring
economy our big vision is something we
call
universal family care one day we should
have a fund
that we all contribute to that we can
all benefit from
that helps us pay for child care
long-term care and paid family leave
basically
everything we need to take care of our
families while we're working
across the lifespan it's like a new
version of social security
it is exactly
[Music]
this week on yang speaks we have the
incredible
founder and visionary and activist
someone i admire
so much on so many levels igen pooh
and we're going to be talking about
georgia in part because her
organization is getting out voters right
now
in georgia as we speak thrilled for this
conversation
and in addition we're going to talk
about yang's potential in the cabinet
you don't want to miss this tune in
andrew if you were secretary of labor
what would you do and i'll tie that to
if someone else is secretary of labor
what should they be doing and what can
they be doing
there is so much you can do at the
department of labor it's very exciting
and fun
and i hope that the next labor secretary
takes full advantage
of our needs and
capacities to hopefully help dig us out
of this hole
so we are down over 10 million jobs at
least
that we know of and economists say that
of the jobs that we've lost will never
return
uh now the department of labor spends
billions of dollars
on education and training programs to
try and connect people back to
opportunities
some of those programs are working
better than others
but we certainly need much much more of
this so
i would pour fuel on any
company organization community college
that is reconnecting people to jobs and
opportunities
i would call it race to a million jobs
and just
come in and say look like what are you
doing what's that you hired
500 pipefitters uh for
these construction sites and projects
what is the actual need for pipefitters
in this environment and if it's 5000
then say wyatt what do you need then
well you need
resources to recruit and enlist
and train and outfit because a lot of
these organizations that i talk to
they're doing great work but they can't
grow to the extent that they want
there's another organization that i love
called kedzie academy and they're taking
typically high school grads and training
them to be
engineers and tech employees they're
doing it at twenty thousand dollars a
pop
uh which is an incredible value because
you're seeing a massive
surge in income among the folks that go
through this program
uh so i talked to the folks at kedzie
and said what are your bottlenecks
and they said look right now we actually
could be doing much more than we're
doing but people don't know about us
so we actually spend a lot of money on
customer acquisition
and we don't have limitless funds and so
the question is well if
the department of labor were to give you
a grant of a certain amount of money
could you grow enrollment significantly
could you train and place more people in
the tech industry and they were like 100
yes so we should be going around
identifying opportunities
like this uh particularly if they're in
communities and community colleges
and then make grants loans
have prizes matching grants
have this team of people scouring the
country just
trying to help folks who are creating
jobs grow
and that would be to me job number one
let me ask you this
when you were running for president you
ripped apart government retraining
programs and things like that so what is
different about
andrew doing this um is it that you
don't have like people to give favors
for and like
[ __ ] programs you're funding or what
what makes it more effective in your end
what you want to do is you don't want to
have a fiction that
uh that you yourself can create
jobs unless you just pay people then the
government can do that you know i mean
that's a role of government
but that's not what we're describing
here what you do is you find
an organization or company or
school that is already demonstrating
success
in creating jobs and you say look i'm
going to be your growth capital
um like i'm not going to administer this
thing
i essentially become the
friendly source of oh yeah the friendly
source of capital that tries to max out
your scale
as quickly as possible and does it in a
way that works for your
operation that's a very different animal
than showing up to a
group of unemployed factory workers and
say hey we're going to retrain you
because you don't have any guarantee
that there's a job waiting for them at
the other end and those programs have
not typically been very successful
you wish that they were so what you want
to do is you don't want to try and
create success you want to find
success and then you want to pour fuel
on it
so that's one thing i would i would do
another thing would be
to establish a future core of young
people who are having trouble
getting a foothold in the economy and
then connect them to
uh infrastructure to green jobs to elder
and adult care to forest care i mean we
need so many new park rangers if we were
going to try and head off these
uh forest fires to veterans
services to government public service
and then put them in position where they
actually have let's call it a year
of experience in these fields and then
can get connected to
a long-term job if they find that it's a
fit there's a massive need on both sides
right now because you have a lot of
young people who are dislocated
and you have tons of needs i would want
to invest in vocational
training and education where something i
said on the trail all the time
is that only six percent of american
high school seniors are in any kind of
apprenticeship or vocational training in
germany that's over fifty percent i mean
look at that gulf
um so maybe we can't get up to fifty
percent but can we get up to fifteen
percent any progress there is good right
yeah any progress there would be
enormous
you know i'd want to update the bureau
of labor statistics reporting
um because right now they don't know
what's going on with the gig economy
they don't know what's going on with the
green economy or the caregiving economy
they don't have
uh these things actually very well laid
out um i
i've looked at the data like that you
know these don't really uh break it out
in that way the gig economy is a bit of
a black box like you know the studies
that are out there
um uh are uh
privately commissioned a lot of time and
um inconclusive
uh i would get away from this headline
unemployment rate i would use the u6
rate instead of the u3 which is what we
hear of that includes
could you make the american scorecard as
secretary of labor you know that's more
the bureau of economic analysis which is
under commerce but labor could do at
least
the labor component of it
so you you could update the measurements
in a way that would i think
be very powerful and emphasize things
like labor force participation rate
which is more telling than
um than the u3 headline unemployment
rate in many of these contexts
that that would make me very very happy
um one thing that would also make me
incredibly happy
is trying to enforce actions
against folks who are abusing this
independent contractor designation
and i understand i've run i've run a
business but
uh the economic incentives to say
everyone's an independent contractor sky
high because then you don't have to pay
benefits you don't have to give them
health care
and we know that employers are abusing
this and on one hand i almost don't
blame you
uh because that's where all your
incentives are but on the other hand
you know we need to start treating
people better and having
better conversations about like whether
someone truly works for your company
or if they're truly an independent
contractor so this is the funnest thing
in the world zack you know
like some of the highest profile abusers
of this designation
vince mcmahon the wwe
uh and they don't want to the ufc they
call their performers
and uh and
athletes independent contractors even
though they're controlling
all aspects of their behavior in many
contexts like wwe performers can't even
go on twitch or cameo and any time they
breed the word union they get fired
that's true both the wwe and the ufc and
that's illegal
so if you the secretary of labor you
could actually go in and say wait a
minute how the heck are you controlling
every aspect of their behavior if
they're an independent contractor
and then if you make them employees you
help them unionize i mean that's like a
massive game changer or an association
in mma's case for wrestlers they should
definitely have a union or join a union
for mma it's a little bit more
complicated
i would do everything i can to encourage
portable benefits programs
that move around independent of work
because
that's just the reality of the 21st
century economy i would try to
put resources to work to help facilitate
interstate migration
and lower licensing requirements for
everything from hairdressers to medical
professionals
i would try and make it you'll love this
one zach this is right up your alley
so there was like a a a fight over the
fiduciary duties
of financial advisors whether they have
responsibilities to you
as the saver um and to disclose fees not
have conflicts of interest etc etc and
believe it or not the department of
labor actually put forward this rule
because they enforce
erisa which is the um the
savings um and pension plans uh
and there was a bit of a legal fight as
to whether
uh you could have this rule um and we
should have this rule it would save
savers 30 billion dollars a year uh you
know if
if you took out all the like the uh kind
of
extra fees that financial advisors are
slipping in there um
and they they're often getting kickbacks
i mean you know just gotta know that
that's happening
um is that close to home for you zach
very i always thought you should have
some of the way that doctors get
malpractic they get sued for malpractice
i think financial advisors should have
that same responsibility particularly
you i mean like there's the horror
stories we would see and they're pretty
they're
not as rare as it this sounds but like
the husband dies the main breadwinner
dies and
the lack of spending or insurance or
planning leaves the wife and
kids or the you know the homemaker and
the children with
nothing or pound mountains of debt
without knowing about it or all these
like liabilities and no clue
like to me that's malpractice um on the
financial advisor's part because some of
the stuff gets so
complicated it can really screw up lives
you know and it's certainly costing us
billions of dollars
it's making the financial advisory
industry richer but you know is that
really the purpose
uh you know the purpose should be to
facilitate retirement savings and the
rest of it
uh i would start a commission on ai and
autonomous vehicles to figure out the
prospective impact of employment i mean
and that's not just truck drivers mean
google just announced that they have ai
that can do the work of call center
workers and you have two million call
center workers united states
uh so they're massive trends coming down
the pike
i would pilot a four day work week and
have companies sign up for that
and shake shack and microsoft have
already experimented with that and then
release data
i mean if you have enough uh name brand
companies
operating in a four day work week i mean
that could really start a movement that
would benefit
us all there's so many fun things you
can do out of labor
uh it was it was fun researching this
and hopefully the next secretary of
labor takes advantage
of what the department can do and i
would argue
no matter what congress needs to
increase the funding the department of
labor
because we're in an historic crisis
right now and what is it
it's a large part of jobs crisis and
where should you be putting money you
should be putting money into people's
hands into small businesses
uh uh to cities and states
but you should also be putting into the
department of labor because
uh if there's an agency that should
theoretically be creating jobs and
helping
uh again pour fuel on efforts that are
doing so
it should be the department of labor
having the same budget when you're in a
jobs crisis as you do during
flush times does not make any sense so
the only other thing i ask is 15
minimum wage we get hit on it or we talk
about a lot we prefer universal basic
income
it's more flexible and it's mobile and
not tied to the job but
like for all the workers suffering now
for lower pay is there something you
would
like how would you handle that given
like if you know your secretary labor
maybe ubi's not getting passed would you
explore a minimum wage or something in
that regard
well the tough part is that the
secretary of labor does not have control
over minimum
wage regs it does have control over
minimum wage reg enforcement
so you can come down on employers that
are
frankly keeping a lot of hours off books
and being like oh yeah we paid you this
much like you can enforce that stuff
i certainly am for a higher minimum wage
but that that's not something
uh the labor department can do itself
got it okay
similar for paid family leave which is
something i'm also very passionate about
um
and uh you can fund things in that
direction but
um it's primarily uh something that
you'd want to
come out of congress uh you could work
with companies that are doing it already
and try and expand it
right well they have it andrew yang's
thoughts on secretary of
labor i think you'd be a fascinating
you're kind of a regulator is what that
is regulator and
lawsuit bringer in chief
well well there are two aspects to it
one is trying to
enforce the laws on the books and
they're really unenforced in many many
environments
we all know that you know it's like you
know that there are all these people
abusing
independent contractors like uh um
even minimum wage which seems freaking
incredible given how low it is
but then there are other things that the
department does too that are actually
growth oriented where we spend billions
of dollars
on programs right now that are meant to
try and connect people to the economy
young people like there's a program
called youth build where we take high
school dropouts and put them on
construction sites to build
housing for like low-income families
so programs that already exist like that
that we need more of in different
segments of the economy
uh for green jobs for carrying jobs for
tech jobs in particular because the
opportunities in each of those fields
are millions of jobs
i just think it'd be great to have
someone thinking outside the box in some
of these traditional roles you know if
you get someone in there that's just
gonna go status quo
country's on fire so that won't help um
it's just
plain and simple you care where you are
democrat republican countries on fire
and you fix it you put
fire out and one person who's known what
people are going through or workers are
going through for so long
is igen pooh she's the director of the
national domestic workers alliance
and uh there probably is not a more
overlooked group than domestic workers
in the
country you know these are so often
uh women women from immigrant
communities
who are kind of invisible and igen has
done
amazing uh work
organizing and fighting for national
domestic workers
uh for years she got a macarthur genius
grant
a number of years ago i know like you
know we're all like whoa
you got a macarthur genius grant a bit
like you're like don you've been like
knighted as a genius if you get that
award generally speaking there's some i
disagree with but generally
it's pretty pretty accurate for an
activist to get that
is a very very big deal uh and and her
organization again is helping on the
ground in georgia i've been a fan of
igens for a long time
uh we actually did some work together
and like a relief project a little while
ago
so here to talk about her work what
we're doing in georgia
and what the future of labor looks like
for a lot of people
in this country igen poop
[Music]
i love subscription services because you
just set it and forget it
and then when you get the thing you
forget you even subscribed you're like
oh
what is this what is this delightful
package
and what could be more delightful than
some vino
bright sellers is a wine subscription
service that helps you find wine you
love
while making it more accessible for
everyone you can take a 30 second quiz
all these companies have quizzes i love
quizzes
and bright sellers will pair you with
unique and personalized wines that are
delivered right to your doorstep
you can seem really sophisticated you
can
relieve some stress in a way that's very
wholesome and healthy and for our
listeners we're giving you fifty percent
off your first six
bottle orders from bright sellers go to
brightsellers.com
yang50 that's bright sellers
c-e-l-l-a-r-s
dot com slash yang50 take their seven
question quiz to get your wine matches
and receive 50
off your first six bottle order i really
like wine but i always sound like an
idiot because i don't understand what's
in it or why
i like certain types so bright sellers
is perfect if you want to sound a little
more impressive with your friends they
send you a case
after you take this quiz and for each
type of wine they give you a card that
has
like the real details but also like some
quick talking points you remember so you
can sound smart be like this is rich in
tannins or this is
made in oak massage
barrels or whatever the heck comes with
it but it's pretty cool
um and very tasty so that is
brightsellers.com yang 50
and get 50 off your first six bottles
[Applause]
hello welcome everyone i am thrilled to
welcome
to the podcast i jan pooh who is
the senior advisor to care in action
which is an advocacy organization
for domestic workers around the country
award-winning author
time 100 alumna macarthur genius grant
award-winning
organizer uh ijen it's so
great to have you here welcome thank you
and thanks for everything you're doing
to save our democracy
thank you for everything you're doing so
people who've been keeping up with us
know that i'm here in georgia you can
tell by the peach
and uh we're trying to support
organizations who are doing work on the
ground who've been getting out the vote
this whole time and caring action
is one of those organizations where you
all have been organizing
workers uh and voters here in georgia
that's right actually the domestic
workers movement has a really long
history and deep roots
in georgia dating all the way back to
1881 when the first washer women
black women went on strike to raise
wages and won
wage increases for thousands of workers
to
the 1970s when the incredible
civil rights leader dorothy bolden
founded the national domestic workers
union
and by the way when she founded the
domestic workers union
she had the only two requirements for
joining
were that you had to be a domestic
worker and you had to be registered to
vote
so civic engagement and voting rights
and voter participation has always been
in kind of the dna of our movement
and we've been building really
intentionally there as a movement since
focused on organizing black domestic
workers who
are working incredibly hard and still
not able to make ends meet still don't
have access to a safety net or
job security or even a single paid sick
day
and we've been organizing to try to
improve conditions
and in 2018 we got deeply involved
in building the power of
women of color voters like domestic
workers in
our democracy and to shape the future of
georgia and
we were so proud to be one of the
largest
field operations in support of stacey
abrams historic campaign for governors
and we focused on hard to reach women of
color voters who are considered
so-called low-propensity voters we see
them as
high-potential high-value voters who can
really transform our electorate to be
much more reflective of who we are as a
country
so for people who are thinking wow so
glad georgia went blue
you have karen action to thank because
they've been working on it for seven
years
you know i mean like this stuff does not
happen overnight
well that is true but i have to say that
black women really led the way in
georgia and have always
really led the way in georgia and oh
certainly not not your organization
exclusively but that there have been
people like you working on it
like stacey abrams absolutely
other orgs so this stuff does not happen
quickly or magically it happens because
people have been
in communities doing the work uh this
whole time
so i'm a huge admirer of yours in large
part because your origin story so i just
wanted to
geek out a little bit because you and i
have a lot in common i don't know how if
you know how much
we have in common so check it out i'm
the the
child of taiwanese american immigrants
my dad had a phd in physics my mom had a
master's in math they came here
there was this period in the 60s when
the u.s was letting in
taiwanese grad students and so they came
here they met each other
and they had me and my brother in the
70s
i think you and i might even have been
born the same year
and then i went to phillips exeter uh
and graduated in 92
uh and then i wound up going to uh
columbia for law school where you went
undergrad
um so the thing that blows my mind about
you i jen
is that you and i i think you know have
those things in common i think pretty
much everything i just stated um
like it could have been you talking but
then but then you did something that was
so
unusual certainly for our community
really for anyone because you know
there aren't many people like you um so
you
have this education that primes you for
doing frankly you know like what a lot
of our peers did out of a place like
columbia which would be
medicine finance consulting business
tech in my case law and the rest of it
but then you
took a very very sharp detour and became
a labor
organizer so i would love to hear how
the heck that happened
wow i had no idea we had that many
experiences in common that's incredible
thank you for naming all of that we have
lots to talk about
but in terms of how i became a labor
organizer
when i was in college at columbia i one
of the reasons why i wanted to go to
columbia was it was in new york city
and the city and its energy
and its diversity in communities and the
size of the asian immigrant community
in new york were some of the reasons why
i wanted to be there
and i started volunteering at a domestic
violence shelter
for asian immigrant women and i could
still speak mandarin so i was actually
of value in terms of being a bilingual
hotline volunteer
and and a lot of the calls
were not just about the struggles of
surviving violence or abuse
but a lot of them were about how hard it
was
to just survive as a mom
as someone working in a low-wage service
job
you know i would hear from women who
were domestic violence survivors who
were working in
nail salons or doing domestic work and
long long hours and still not able to
pay the rent or you know cover the
expenses related to school
for kids and i just remember thinking
like how could it be that there's so
many people who work so hard
and do everything right and survive so
much and still can't make a decent
living and take care of the people they
love
and that kind of led me down a path of
trying to figure out how we make
work better for women especially women
in our communities women of color
um women who are really struggling at
the bottom of the economy where
we just don't value so much work that's
actually
essential there are a lot of people who
frankly volunteer at nonprofits when
they're in college
um but then they don't make a career out
of it in the same way that you have so
like
the thing that again i just want because
i'm genuinely curious i think you can
tell
is so you're an undergrad you're
volunteering downtown um
and then like how are you spending your
summers like and what is your first
job um when you graduate from school
and also like how is your family taking
this in but i'd love to start really
like with
what your college career looked like and
then what what your first job was
yeah so in college i volunteered
at the new york asian women's shelter
and then also at the committee against
anti-asian violence as you mentioned
where we started the women workers
project that led to
lots of the other work to organize
domestic workers
and then i also on campus was involved
in
a campaign in 1996 to win
ethnic studies on campus at columbia
so in the spring of 1996 there was kind
of a multiracial coalition of students
who came together
to fight for an ethnic studies
department and
the combination of the volunteering on
campus
or the volunteering outside of campus
and the community
and the work to try to change how things
worked
on campus and working across race
it was really transformative to me like
i the fact that we actually waged a
campaign
we took over buildings we went on hunger
strike we did all kinds of stuff
and we won there's now a center for the
study of ethnicity and race
at columbia because of the activism that
we did and i think i got kind of
addicted to
winning like i just got really
excited about the fact that you're like
one for one what else can i do
yeah i kind of was like hey you could
get just like regular people together
get together and fight for something and
make some real
change that can affect future
generations and i
think i kind of caught the bug but i
didn't know that you could
make it a career to be honest andrea
yeah exactly
yeah no there was no i did not think of
it as a career i
thought maybe i would be a writer
i was tutoring at the borough of
manhattan community college
as a you know in the summers and then
after i graduated
to help people prepare for the writing
assessment test
i thought i would like get some kind of
a job to pay the bills while i wrote
um sure maybe publishing or something
like that yeah exactly yeah i also
worked in restaurants i was
waited tables and i worked as a
bartender
and i was a busboy at a chinese
restaurant in upstate new york the
imperial one
yeah how old were you when did you do
that i was in my teens
uh my chinese was too shoddy for me to
translate orders
so i couldn't be a waiter i was like in
some ways
because that's what you had to do to get
the orders to the kitchen you had to
like you know write in chinese because
the cooks don't uh speak english so that
so they were um anyway so yeah
we had that experience in common too it
sounds like though you were it sounds
like you were
further up the server food chain than i
was because you're chinese it sounds
like it's better
well i think my grandparents raised me
so
they taught me mandarin as my first
language but
you know when you're mainly a child
learning a language so i feel like i
have
like a 10 year old's level of vocabulary
i don't even know what people know this
about me i jen but i got left back in
chinese school over and over again so
like that the folks
like that the kids next to me were just
like like i was getting bigger and
bigger
like the class always staying the same
size like this overgrown
third grader
i had a similar experience in taiwan
because when i went and spent
summers in taiwan with my grandparents
they sent me to school
because the school year last much longer
in taiwan and so i was a giant second
grader in a kindergarten class and like
what kids wet their pants during nap
time and i was
so embarrassed to be like a huge kid
with all these so-called babies and yeah
so i mean so that that sounds like some
tiger apparently i mean i'm sure it
wasn't they just want to see family but
it's like this american school you're
not long enough let's
bring you back to taiwan and just like
put you locally just keep that school
year going
um that's some funny stuff uh yeah i
mean i
i like i didn't even know you could do
that um how many
summers did you have this extended
school experience was it just second
grade or did it happen later too
no i was i went i spent every summer
of my childhood i think until maybe
fourth grade
in in taiwan with my grandparents
um wow when you're close to them that's
beautiful
yes uh yes very very close and
my grandmother in particular is like my
hero she just passed away recently
actually
um mm-hmm yeah my grandmother as well
um oh religion yeah
last year while i was running uh for
president uh my grandmother passed
i'm so sorry to hear that
[Music]
you know what time it is it's time to
talk about your data
and why it is getting ripped every time
you go on the
internet unless you use a vpn
and the vpn you should use according to
us is expressvpn because expressvpn
is the number one rated by cnet
wired and other people who check it out
for
a living companies use it we recommend
it you should use it too
it safeguards your data makes it so that
no one can see what you're doing
you can access some of that really racy
foreign content
because you can take him into the
internet in another country
if this all sounds like your jam
expressvpn.com
yang right now you can get three months
of expressvpn for
free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang visit expressvpn.com to learn more
i just went to my parents house for
thanksgiving
and happy to say my vpn worked there too
so i got to stream because i had frankly
really crappy wi-fi and i was a little
worried and it worked great this thing
works wherever it's easy to plug in
expressvpn.com yang visit expressvpn.com
yang and get three extra months of
expressvpn for free
so let's fast forward again to when
you're coming out of college
um so you're waiting tables you're doing
uh various things you're a bartender
and so like how did you figure out that
activism was an actual career choice
after you'd had this
massive victory or senior spring i
didn't really know that it was
um we at when i was working
when i was volunteering at cav and we
started the women workers project the
committee against anti-asian violence
we started the women workers project as
kind of an all-volunteer committee
to do outreach to women working in
different low-wage service jobs and
to try to organize for better conditions
and um
we were all volunteer and then
we realized that we needed somebody full
time
who would get up every day and really be
thinking about how to move this work
forward and follow through
and keep in touch with the workers we
were meeting and
and we put together a job description we
applied for
some grant money to fund the position
and i really didn't think that i would
do that but when
nobody applied for the job everyone in
the volunteer committee convinced me to
do it
so i started out doing it part-time for
a while and then it became
full-time and i think what i'll say is
that
even then i didn't think of it as
my life's path i just kind of i think i
followed the women that i met
and organized with along the way and
was so moved by the incredible courage
and resilience of
the women that i would meet in the work
and i just kind of took their lead and
kept going and um and
we would win along the way and that also
kept me going
wow so you're kind of you're tutoring
you're
uh bartending
and then you're volunteering and then
the volunteerism gets to a point it's
like hey someone should actually start
doing this
uh like part time so do you remember who
the original grantors were to fund
the this part-time and then full-time
position
i think the new york women's foundation
and
the ms foundation maybe
um the north star was a while ago
obviously
yeah some some of the grassroots social
justice
foundations in new york city really
important early supporters for seed
projects like that
so listen to this philanthropists and
funders
you end up funding these uh these
positions and then sometimes they end up
mushrooming into these world-changing
activists
doesn't happen you know if you don't
fund it who knows maybe igen is
uh is uh doing something else right now
you never know so philanthropists you
gotta get in there early
uh so so you're working um
uh eventually a full-time role
um for cav and then you wound up
transitioning
into uh starting your own um or
organizing really domestic workers and
starting an organization to that effect
um what is that arc like because i you
know i can see the volunteer i can see
okay
no one else wants to do it so everyone's
like hi jen you do it and one of the
things that happens in these
environments
it's a little bit like a school project
where responsibility ends up falling on
whoever the most competent
person is you know what i mean like like
if if you have like a class project and
there are five of you and then there's
one person who's on top of it and the
other four
they're not as good so that everyone's
like
ooh person who's on top of it that's
like so i can i can imagine that
happening and i can imagine
um you know you're doing it full-time
but then there was like this entire arc
where you go from
part-time to full-time to actually
starting your own organization which is
a very very big deal
and this i i'd imagine happened this arc
transpired
it seems like throughout your 20s
well one thing that your listeners
should really know is that none of these
things are because of singular
individuals or processes and
at least in my experience i've been
organizing for
25 years and it has always been a
collective effort
and maybe my name is on paper as the
staff person
or as the executive director as a
co-founder
but it takes groups of us
squads it's always a squad effort i find
and i'm sure you found this too with
your campaign andrews like
it took like there was just like an
essential core group
every time to really take the work to
the next level
and um and that's really i think the
story of
the domestic workers movement that i've
been a part of has been
it was like a group of filipino domestic
workers who decide to take the project
multiracial
and then a group of caribbean women who
decide to
really expand strengthen the work in new
york city
together with filipinas and south asian
women and latina
workers and then a group of new york
workers
then get together with a group of
workers from la
dc seattle san francisco and then we
launched the national alliance
we had 50 co-founders of the national
alliance
in 2007 and then a group of us
you know in the domestic workers
movement after the 2016 elections
you know a bunch of domestic workers
said we need an
advocacy platform we have to be able to
use every tool at our disposal
to make this democracy to save our
democracy
and to make it work for us and so that's
how karen action was formed and
it was never ever me i i'm often the
fundraiser
to be honest
but um there's so much leadership and so
much collective leadership behind
every effort and every breakthrough and
and so many of the people who made
this moment in the movement possible
they're names that you'll never hear of
but who were absolutely essential to the
work
[Music]
i recently just tweeted drink water
which is always a good idea
the more you're hydrated the better off
your body's going to be it's something
really easy
uh and healthy you can do for yourself
but a lot of us don't even do that
frankly i mean let's be honest so how
can you make it more
active and efficient take liquid
iv you put this stuff in water
and then it like supercharges water so
you drink it
and it's like you're getting three times
the hydration
i know it's freaking magic of science so
that sounds like the kind of thing that
would actually
have you get the hydration you need
liquid iv
is for you so one of those things i wish
we had on the campaign andrew because
what you're doing in the campaign you're
trying to stay sick
the whole time and you're just pounding
bottles of water and then frankly
you have to go to the bathroom the whole
time because you're just literally
pounding water all day long
in this case one of these is like three
plus bottles of water
and it actually tastes pretty good i
like the lemongrass ginger one that i've
done
they've got one that literally tastes
like apple pie which is kind of crazy um
watermelon's great they got basic lemon
lime too a ton of different flavors and
simple it's a quick pouch
you can put it on the road throw it in
your suitcase throw your backpack it's
great and it works you feel better you
feel like you don't need to drink so
much water because you literally are
hydrated you can get 25 off when you go
to liquid iv.com
and use the code yang at checkout that's
25 off anything you order
when you use promo code yang at
liquidiv.com
get better hydration today liquidity.com
promo code yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so servant leaders like yourself so you
get
to to an organization uh or a group of
people and you see the need i mean
the need you're trying to address is
obviously monumental
uh like the um
mistreatment of and um systematic
marginalization of domestic workers i
mean you knew it like
it's very very uh pervasive
it's like you know it's political it's
economic it's human like
it it's everything um so you get
and i can relate to some of these
experiences uh and i would never put
myself anywhere near
you in terms of activism but i did start
a non-profit
and one of the things that happens when
you start a non-profit if you
are like let's call it like the founder
the co-founder whatever it happens to be
um it really does translate to
fundraiser in chief you know
and like like your job is to raise that
money when i started this nonprofit i
thought the idea for the nonprofit spoke
for itself
and no one needed to hear about andrew
yang so much
but then someone that worked with me at
the nonprofit said andrew in order for
the
organization to raise money like this
like andrew yang needs to be this or
higher
like you need to see anything that
accrues to you
as good for the organization and if no
one knows who you are cares about you
the organization's not actually going to
succeed and this is someone who was
working with me at the organization i
really needed that boost
uh thank you mike tarulo for for saying
this to me
um but i needed that boost to be like
okay so like i guess it's okay if i
show up to these conferences and
sit on a panel or show up to stuff and
and try and interject myself or elevate
my own profile
because it makes me more effective
fundraiser and the fact is if you're
serious about trying to start an
organization or
raise money that stuff's very very
useful so that was like a very big
shift for me because you don't want it
to be about you you want it to be about
the work
and the the folks who are actually doing
the work very often
um uh but the reality of raising money
is like you know it's very helpful for
people to actually think oh yeah i saw
that person at that conference or in
your case
you've won like every award in the book
and there's part of you i'm sure that's
like uh who cares about the awards but
then
uh but you know the awards end up
opening doors for you so that
you know what started out as a meeting
with like a funder at this level like
eventually becomes a meeting at this
level
yeah no it's it's a really interesting
thing
because i don't think any of us get into
this work to be on panels or go on tv
my dream is to be on a panel at some
social innovation
conference you know and
um and i'm an introvert so the idea of
going on msnbc is like horrifying for me
but you know you do it in the service of
the work and then
you do realize that that visibility is
really important
not for you but for the work and the
goals of your work
and um and but it's still kind of
conflicted
and i remember um when i
learned that i was gonna be a recipient
of the macarthur
fellowship the genius award for anyone
who doesn't know
anyway continue
reaction was like i don't
this no this is not this is not right
um you know i'm a part of a movement and
uh
to single me out that if there's any
genius here it's in the collective
and um so you know i remember feeling
really
conflicted and weird and exposed and
and i think um where i've come
is that you know if you're using your
platform
in the service of good that in some ways
you're
leaving power on the table by not you
know
oh yeah especially for someone like you
now it's like
you know like you now have the ability
to access
platforms and resources that would be
immensely helpful
for the movement in a way that frankly
it's like very very tough for someone
else to do that hasn't built that up
over time
yeah but i but i actually uh have this
in common with you too i jen is that i
also am an introvert
uh are you really yeah yeah
i you know i got tested in the rest of
it but also i know for myself
you know my favorite thing to do is to
read like i was a very bookwormy kid
and running for office is certainly like
the opposite of that activity
uh and you know like for me the campaign
was about
this set of ideas that i wanted to put
out there and i was always like look
like if if we get something like
universal basic income passed and
everyone just forgets
about andrew yang i would be thrilled
like you can you know and and it's one
of the things that's weird about me is
that
uh like it's like you where it's like i
see it as a tool
like um and i've got like tools to try
and reach goals and like make positive
things happen
but i really don't care about
uh about what many people would regard
as like that you know the
the trappings of a public life or
whatnot
that if you just like left me alone to
like chill out with the
family and like read books and maybe
write some stuff i mean i i do enjoy
writing too so
you know it's and it's helpful too on
that side it's like there are many
awesome writers
who uh have a hard time getting book
deals because like they don't have
public profiles
which you know is that is that correct
or accurate it's like well
um you know it stinks uh and i can very
well see myself as one of those
people because i was the awkward
introverted uh asian kid growing up um
and most people i don't know
like regard me as that now because at
this point now i've got like this
uh different set of public-facing tools
i guess
where uh when you talk about cringing at
the idea of going on msnbc it's like i
actually pop up on tv kind of on the
regular now because it's sort of like
notice like something i signed up for
which
also let me say was freaking shocking to
me
um because going on those cable news
hits
was one of my least favorite uh aspects
of campaigning
um i was genuinely stunned when cnn
called me like the day after i dropped
down was like hey you want to come on
tv and like i was like really anyway
so there's a so there's a very
long-winded way of saying um i think
uh you and i have the introversion uh
thing in common so i understand
like how you have to push through it all
the time
no that's right and i imagine in your
campaign you had to push through
a lot of um different kinds of i mean
i can't think of a more extroverted
experience than running for president of
the united states
to be honest um i'm curious how did you
re-re-generate your energy
through the campaign afterwards or even
during like how did you
because i know for me if i'm having a
very externally oriented day like a lot
of public speaking or events or
something
i really need the time afterwards to
just kind of be quiet
and do my yoga or whatever what do you
do
i think my team understood me uh where
like i would go give a town hall and be
like yeah and we're gonna like do this
and you know humanize the economy and
like let's let's uh
change the world and i get back in the
car and then all of a sudden it'd be
like
you know like leave me alone
my team would just like let me
yeah like like let me and in some cases
the way i would recharge would be
like you know i might um sit there and
silently read something
um you know i i might read something
that would be
frankly unrelated to politics like i
might like read a sports article or
something like that like like that might
be a way that i could
uh recharge between events even because
in many cases i
like you know the car would stop and i'd
have another event and then someone
would go to my ear and say like okay
this is the town you're in like
like like these uh this is the person
who's introducing you like yeah they're
kind of like
variables that i would need um it wasn't
easy i jen though like i it became
um it was wild and then i pushed myself
further than i
had ever had to before and
i i started running in like late 2017
but no one paid any attention
um and then the the spotlight was very
bright uh
in late 2019
uh early 2020 um and so uh so i had to
develop adaptations i never
thought i would uh like i consider
myself very
self-sufficient i like doing my own
thing more so than having
a group of people around me like a
coterie or attendance or staff or
whatever
but then down the stretch and the
campaign i had like a giant retinue
and they're doing everything and it was
it was like so
uh uncomfortable but it just made a lot
more
sense um just like a basic thing where
like i would get to a hotel room and
like the hotel room had been like
advanced
which means like my luggage was there
and the rest of it like you know i spent
like a year and a half just like
hauling my luggage and doing this and
that then all of a sudden like yeah
it's like some genie came in and like
you know put put the room together
and you know there's a period where
you're like well this sucks um but then
like there's a period also where it's
like well i guess this is like
how we have to function if i'm going to
you know do five of these town halls
like tomorrow and not have to
think about certain things um so it
really was what some of what you're
describing
like those extraversion days taken to
the extreme like ramped up to 11 or 12
like past any
sane limit honestly
but i i had the the goal in mind the
whole time was like i have a chance to
potentially accelerate the end of
poverty
like so so there was like never you know
it's like you'd get up and just be like
just
do whatever must be done because uh
like i felt like there was an
opportunity that i might never see again
um and like i already felt like there
were so many people who'd invested their
hopes
and aspirations for a better life in
what we were doing
so i felt all of this energy
responsibility opportunity
and then when the campaign ended it was
a little bit like
uh like i'd been running on this
incredible
kind of crowd-sourced energy that then
um that that then
left me i didn't leave me in the sense
that you know people still seem to
you know like me and and what now which
i appreciate thank you yang yang love
you um
but like that but but but you know it
was a very big change
um and then the downshift was so weird
uh
you know like because you you're more
extroverted than you ever had to be
uh and and then i kind of had this
strange transition into
um uh into
like being on tv sometimes but not all
the time like uh like i didn't have the
same
campaign uh team around me all the time
i was a public figure for the first time
so if i just walked around the streets
of new york people would be like hey
andrew yang and i was like
this is new and weird yeah totally like
like this and a lot of responsibility
too as the first api
candidate
to reach the kind of momentum
that you had i mean that's it was i'm
sure
that must have been challenging in terms
of the expectations
well one thing i haven't talked about a
lot eigen but i've been reflecting on a
little bit more
um is that i think as an asian-american
man
or a boy you know in the past or what
not i gen
genuinely thought i had this kind of
invisibility cloak that i could put on
any time i wanted
uh where if you like walk into a deli or
restaurant
like no one pays much attention to you
if like you you're not really trying to
be
you know generating attention uh and so
i was so used to that anonymity that i
think
frankly was like ramped up by being
asian you know it's like
like i think you know maybe maybe
everyone thinks they can just blend into
the woodwork but i certainly felt that
to like i think a slightly higher degree
because
i just don't think people pay that much
attention to it
it's what you were like walking around
and and so the first time someone
recognized me when i was not wearing
anything related to the campaign where i
just had like you know sweats and a
hoodie on and someone was like hey
andrew yang i was like you know who i am
like the whole thing just
discombobulated me so
much and then even after it happened i
was like yeah that that person
must have been weird
um so so the the visibility was
something that
i like i never anticipated i like i
you know it's funny i ran for president
and still never expected that to happen
which is very odd given that you know
you
presume if you're going to be at least
somewhat successful like that might
happen
but like i genuinely never expected it
to and
was was confused by the adjustment
yeah i remember thinking um
you know as a fellow asian american i
remember thinking
what an incredible responsibility
um and like
and like wow do you have i remember
wondering like do you have a
kitchen cabinet of other api leaders who
you could consult
on how to navigate at all because
having to do that alone must have been
really challenging and i remember i'll
i'll just be totally honest like
some of the calls some of the calls you
would make around like leaning into the
math thing
or talking about you're american
and raising you know wearing flags and
things like that i just remember being
like
oh no you know like let's not
um reinforce stereotypes that could be
really challenging but then i also
understood that there was
a really important
need for you to claim your identity in a
way that was authentic to you
and and the responsibility of having to
then think about representation of all
of us
in this role of you trying to just lead
is one that's just fundamentally unfair
and a reflection of white supremacy
itself
wow well i mean that certainly lets me
off the hook for a lot of things
like i know enough about how anti-asian
racism works
that um i know that you were in a really
tough spot
and so yeah there were many moments i
wish i could have like called you up on
the bat phone and been like hey andrew
no let's not do this
well you know what what's funny i jed is
that um you somehow would have had to
make those calls like
before the fact and i probably didn't
even know i was going to do it before
the fact
so it would have been to try to insulate
me from some decision i was going to
make
you know five minutes later uh i mean i
i have um
can i say one thing though before you
continue which is that i
think that it was also amazing to watch
um you become like a as an organizer
right
as you like i watched your campaign
early and then how it evolved and you
became like a better and better
campaigner like
every day you got sharper you got
stronger you were just like and it was
kind of
amazing to watch um and that moment
when like you and your life came out
about
autism and your experience with your
child like that was so important
and could have easily not happened and
so i just think
it was also very historic and so
even if i had some disagreements along
the way i was also like
go you go you know along the way and
this is before you knew that you and i
had so much in common
that's right that's right exactly
well i certainly appreciate it and
uh yeah i like that i mean i i genuinely
feel like your arc and mine have been
similar uh and i'm really inspired by
you because
i feel like and let you know but like
what i've gone through over this
last period of time um like you've been
in it for
you said 25 years uh and you started in
in a a line of work i guess i'll return
to something i was curious about earlier
which is like what did your parents
think about the fact that
that their daughter like uh has been
fighting for
uh domestic workers uh rights for
this period of time i mean i assume now
it's probably different than
when you were in your 20s getting
started
yeah for sure um for sure it's different
now
um i mean i definitely i
i was really lucky that my parents were
very understanding and
my mother do you have siblings i have a
younger sister
yeah she's a filmmaker in los angeles
she's awesome wow neither of us neither
of us went into science or medicine
and my parents were really supportive of
us throughout
i think wrapping their heads around how
how i was going to make a living
was like a question um but like that
network pays
like questions yeah exactly exactly like
that's a job
um but i think and and also what the job
was like what is the community organizer
what is you know um but i think that
they knew
they're both very caring individuals and
justice minded and
i think that they liked the fact that i
was pursuing
something that i was really passionate
about and
and both of them did the same and
they're both incredibly passionate about
their work and committed to it as like
some
real driving force higher purpose and i
think they were glad that i found that
for myself even if they had questions
about
livelihood issues along the way um
i feel like you and your sister could
have a competition it's like which of us
chose
a more financially impractical career
path
and then your sister is like what's that
you're a community organizer i'm going
to go you want better
independent filmmaker like
maybe you gave her cover for your
parents where she was like well
i mean heck look at hijab like they
can't be too bad if i become a
like a creative yeah no
were your parents supportive of you
they were sad when i left the law
because i you know i had a secure
professional career and my parents were
very happy about that and then when i
left to become an entrepreneur
and a failed entrepreneur that and that
was not easy for them
and then it became very confusing to
them i was always working on various
startups
uh two frankly low degrees of success
for a number of years
[Laughter]
so they were pretty sad about that
um they they became enthusiastic about
my political run only after
the fact like when i broached it to them
uh they were not
pumped about it which was probably
fairly sane of them
um i mean and then later they became my
biggest boosters
uh in the scheme of parents uh
and asian parents in particular my
parents have been awesome you know that
there was never any like uh
um attempt to try and um
change my decision or path there were
certain levels of concern
but but but there was never like uh you
know you're making a mistake and you
know i'm going to try and
like drive you to do this and not this i
mean one of the things i said when i
left the law i was like look i'm not
going to ask you for a dime so don't
worry about it it's
my decision and like i'll handle the
responsibility like the consequences
will be mine and not yours
maybe you can't brag about me to your
friends anymore but you know you'll
survive
was what i said to them um which maybe
it was a little obnoxious but
[Laughter]
yeah so but i in the scheme of things my
parents have been tremendous
uh and we've always had a very loving
and communicative relationship
uh even if they weren't thrilled with my
choices
yeah that's great we're both very lucky
[Music]
[Applause]
it has been tough to eat right to stay
healthy during this time
i know we're we're all there uh i don't
know about the rest of you just go into
the kitchen
and just look for something to eat
well one of the things that's keeping us
healthy during this time
is athletic greens it contains 75
vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients including a probiotic so you
feel like your gut is working better and
it really does feel like your
everything's working better if you
ingest
athletic greens just mix it with water
down that thing and you feel like you
had
a meals worth of nutrition and then some
so one tasty scoop of athletic greens
contains 75 vitamins
minerals and whole food-sourced
ingredients including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more
and they all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet
increase your energy and focus aid with
digestion and support a healthy immune
system so i love this because it helps
me with my stomach
just ever i can eat spicy foods and i
take athletic greens in the beginning of
the day
i have no problem digesting some of the
crazy things i normally eat
and i feel healthier when i do it and if
you decide to try athletic greens right
now you get a free one-year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs in case
you're doing some traveling
simply visit athleticgreens.comyang and
join experts athletes and health
conscious consumers around the world who
make a daily commitment to their health
every day that's athleticgreens.comyang
and get your free year supply of vitamin
d and five free travel packs today
one of the things i want to try and
unpack is um
the scale of the mistreatment of
domestic workers
uh and so here's the thing that happens
all right so we all know
i'm running around being like hey ai
automation technology it's gonna like
decimate
you know a lot of the most common jobs
the economy and then a lot of people
say and this is dumb i'm just saying
this is the straw man i just want to
explain how dumb it is
but people will be like it's okay
because then we will have like a caring
economy
and everyone will just like look out for
each other and take care of the elderly
and all will be
human and glorious and then i say okay i
love that vision and i'm all for that
vision
but the people who are currently doing
that work now
uh are underpaid exploited
uh really high turnover um it's
both emotionally and physically
injurious uh
and and sometimes i share a story where
i was like a home health care aide for
15 minutes or so
there was like an elderly person and we
needed to like move them
um across the room and i was just
enlisted to help and i was like sure you
know i'm like able-bodied person let's
do this thing
uh and then we like moved uh the elderly
gentleman
um across the room and my back hurt like
immediately thereafter it's like i moved
this person
i i've been doing it for all of 15
minutes so so when i say to the people
who are positing this caring economy
it's like hey
fyi the people who are currently doing
it are
exploited they're predominantly women of
color uh
turnover sky high in this industry
because it's so brutally difficult
so what is the plan to transition from
the current economy to the carrying
economy that does not
involve a massive transferal of
tens of billions of dollars a year like
uh
you know is that's like the question i
pose them
um and and it's frustrating to me
because people just like traffic and
abstraction so much
it's like like do you believe in the
caring economy like yeah we all believe
in it it's like
are you willing to invest in it in like
a real way are you willing to treat the
people who are currently doing it
like at a certain level where they can
actually live like sustainable lives and
not
um be exploited left and right you know
or it's like the folks who are like
taking care of our grandparents like
don't have health care themselves it's
like does that make sense
to anyone like we're we're just gonna
like rely upon
um this class of people that we're just
gonna pretend doesn't exist
yeah no totally i mean i'm so glad you
brought this up because
we actually do have a plan
joe biden and kamala harris announced a
21st century
caregiving plan to invest in the care
economy
for the 21st century as part of its
economic agenda
and it's the first time really that
their a presidential campaign made
investments in the care economy
a core part of its economic agenda not
the women's agenda
not the work family balance agenda the
economic agenda
because of the understanding of its
fundamental nature
and our economy and the need to invest
in it
like infrastructure right we think about
infrastructure
it's a human infrastructure it's like if
infrastructure is all that enables
commerce and prosperity
and our economy to function what could
be more fundamental
than caregiving child access to child
care
access to elder care support for people
with disabilities
that is essential infrastructure that
we've never
ever invested in which is why we have
all these black and brown women who are
working in jobs where they can't survive
trying to live off of seventeen thousand
dollars a year
without health care and so there is
actually a plan
that the president-elect announced
during his campaign
to make caregiving jobs living wage jobs
with benefits and a union
and to expand access to child care and
long-term services in the home in the
community
really big deal but i also want to say
that this is actually just
a step like this doesn't do the trick i
mean it'd be a tremendous step forward
it would be a huge game changer i mean
oh my god
but our big vision is something we call
universal family care i don't know if
i've ever shared this idea with you and
but the idea is that one day we should
have a fund
that we all contribute to that we can
all benefit from
that helps us pay for child care
long-term care and paid family leave
basically
everything we need to take care of our
families while we're working
across the lifespan it's like a new
version of social security
it is exactly and it is the perfect
thing for social insurance because
social insurance works best when there's
a really large risk pool
this would be the largest pool in
history because it would be all of us we
all need care
and and it would make care
so much more affordable and we could
actually innovate
and make the jobs better and we could do
so much because we would be investing
in our caregiving systems as
infrastructure for the 21st century
so that's why i love this so much so
this is the universal
family care fund is that like the name
we just call it universal family care
universal family care i am on board
which is probably shocking
oh really because i mean you know i mean
i've obviously been
saying we need to humanize the economy
and put money into people's hands we can
do
uh what we need and the caregiving
economy gets
ignored by the market economy a whole
lot of the time
and so what's been happening for years
is just there are these folks who've uh
been doing it because you know of a
variety of reasons
but it's uh getting worse and worse for
them
you know and like you you can see it in
some like the most basic things
i have a perspective on this that you
know others may not agree with but
um you can see it very clearly in the
fact that just people are having fewer
kids
you know you look up and be like hey
guess what like you know we're in this
like punitive economy where
everyone's just uh having to grind out
like you know
subsistence living and so people are
like well you know you can't have kids
under these circumstances and so you
have just like fewer people
making that move and then if you do have
kids then it turns out the resources
aren't there
you know like when you get there and
you're like wait what is daycare cost
what's going on
well then you have covid where
and i actually want to talk to you about
covet and automation because i'm curious
on your take on it
if kovid's going to accelerate the worst
aspects of automation
oh yeah already done right that's what i
that's what i yeah that's what i've been
afraid of but um
10 years and 10 weeks is what i've been
saying hi jen we've gone through 10
years and 10 weeks
this took the timeline and just like
accelerated it very very quickly
and half of companies came out and said
we're investing more in automation
uh because it just makes business sense
um
so you're seeing a lot of companies that
were on the border
just committing uh you know you like
like sam's club came out and said all of
their locations will be cleaned by
robots
uh tyson foods said that they're gonna
replace meat packing workers with robots
google said that they have ai they can
do the work of call center
workers that would have happened anyway
that probably is coveted independent
but the other two things were covid
related
well the thing also that my economist
friend larry katz at harvard explained
to me is that some of the
i mean automation has always been a part
of our lives right always
but the some of the the resilience
that we've seen in our economy has to do
with the length of time
that we have to actually see
adaptations and whatnot yeah exactly and
create new jobs that you can't foresee
right
and so that some some technological
advances do create new
um jobs right but that happens through
time
and when you have an accelerated time
frame
for automation like what happened with
covid
there's not enough time for the
resilience piece
to work itself out yes
yeah it makes me very very concerned and
scared
honestly uh it's like i have a sense as
to
what kovit has done um to
workers it's been catastrophic
and our legislators haven't really
responded to it uh meaningfully
in their right ways at all since march
first i can't believe we still don't
have an essential worker's bill of
rights
i just i can't believe it so you've
gotten me very excited about the fact
that joe and kamilah proposed this plan
um on the campaign uh and so
i'd imagine that this plan requires
legislation
uh is that accurate yep i mean it's
it it requires action on the part of
congress so it can be done through
budget reconciliation
but it does need action on the part of
congress
and champions in congress and
and a real push a real mandate from
people
and so that's what we've been trying to
organize i've been really focused on
rallying all the troops the caregivers
the older people who need care
people who are in need of child care and
long-term care
coming together we actually have a whole
group
a coalition we call the care
infrastructure table
where child care advocates paid leave
advocates and long-term care advocates
are all working together
to try to make the caregiving plan a
reality
what what is the uh saying it's like
we're all either
uh caregivers now or will or will
need a kid or a caregiver yeah it's like
like only four categories i think it's
either
like but um you probably know the saying
i just mangled it go ahead can you
well former first lady rosslyn carter
one of our
best advocates for family caregivers she
says that there's only four kinds of
people in the world
people who are caregivers or will be
caregivers
people who need care or will need care
and my addition to that is that usually
we're more than one of those
categories at any given moment
most of us are receiving care of some
sort and providing it in some way or
another and
we have very little support in order to
do that and it's such an important part
of our lives
the big breakthrough on caregiving and
the kova crisis though is that
we used to see caregiving as this like
personal
individual responsibility and if you
couldn't figure out how to afford child
care or how to manage
long-term care for your parent it's
because you failed you suck
like you're a bad parent or you're a bad
daughter
and what kovid taught us is that this is
actually a huge
challenge that requires a collective
public policy solution
yes you know and hopefully
covet hopefully has just put to rest a
lot of the [ __ ] that's like the only
kind of silver lining i can kind of try
and take solace in
um because there's been a lot of like
well must be your fault and then now
it's like is it really the bartender's
fault that they don't have a job right
now you know it's like
it doesn't make any sense very well said
put to rest a lot of the [ __ ] i like
that i hope so and i hope we
respond appropriately legislatively it's
why i'm here in georgia
and it's why that you are doing the work
you're doing
um in georgia to help or your your
organization
um so if someone wanted to help you and
your work
help organize for uh caregivers in a
more human-centered economy like what's
the
place that you would direct them to if
they wanted to put
time resources money caren action
dot us is our url
that's care caren action dot us and
there are volunteer opportunities you
can always donate
and support um and
um and we're really well connected in
georgia to
all of the organizations who are working
on
organizing building power making change
in georgia year round
and this election in particular and the
senate runoff
and there's a coalition of groups called
georgia engage
that is working on mobilizing voters
to make sure that
john ossoff and reverend warnock win
and for your api listeners there's a
special asian american advocacy fund
and they have a pac and they have a
brilliant plan
to turn out aapi voters in georgia for
the special elections and
four point seven percent of georgia
voters just thrown out there
exactly it's huge we can really make the
difference here and so
um if you want to support them it's
asians
asians for georgia they're doing amazing
work in our community
well you're doing amazing work for all
of us igen thank you for everything
you've done
i it's truly inspiring to me to see
someone
that i have so much in common with that
has made the choices and impact that
you've made
like i i find myself to be something of
uh an unintentional activist i suppose
like i i see myself as a problem solver
and then i realize that the biggest
problems
uh are bearing down on us that require
uh
an invigorated public sector in a way
that has not been
um and so i you know ran for president
and did a bunch of other things but
you've been doing so i don't know
i mean but genuinely still like it
struck me as like well that's like the
only logical way to try and solve this
stuff
um uh and but you've been doing the work
uh in such like a genuine selfless human
way for decades
um and uh you know i i'm so glad that
you see opportunities
for uh your work to actually come to
fruition in the next number
of days and weeks because we really need
you to win you know talk about your win
when you were 22 or whatever like we
need you to win now
like much much bigger you know much more
so than even then so thank you
thank you so much yes no my big slogan
for 2020 is winning is self-care
so i'll take it self-care
yes exactly and look i really
really appreciate you and all of the
ways that you have courageously stepped
up
and stepped forward and i mean the
ambition
of having big ideas
for solving big problems and then doing
big things like run for president i just
love it
oh thank you i think thank you i
appreciate it
yeah um it's well thank you
uh i'm just grateful to my wife every
day for
putting up with
with my being gone all that time and
um you know uh so but thank you it
really means a lot to me coming from
someone like you
well more soon let's do some stuff
together let's win
georgia and thank you for being there
and then um and then let's do more let's
win the care agenda
let's end poverty universal family care
let's do it
university family care amazing yeah i i
would love to team up with you
any one thing i can do to be helpful uh
for sure igen you're a champion for
humanity that's the way i'd see you
thank you so much yeah thrilled to be
connected thank you for listening in i
hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]